h m under attack in china
sticks to stance with angered beijing
this is a story from wall street journal
the chief executive of h
m helena helmerson said that the fashion
giant
wants to be responsible by your standing
by a human rights position that anger
beijing can trigger the brand's
disappearance from china's internet last
week china's leading e-commerce ride
hailing uh daily deals and map
applications removed
any reference to h m after statement at
issue last year about not sourcing
material
from xinjiang major cotton production
region in china suddenly went viral
alexander shapiro head of strategy at
beijing branding agency
pbb creative said h m essentially has
two choices it can
keep its head down and hope the boycott
ends quietly or it could stick
by its human rights stance risking sales
indefinitely
it could also preemptively pull out a
move that could benefit the brand
outside china
if it is seen as a as willing to stand
up to beijing the attention
could have been more valued than your
chinese business he said
thoughts this is china china decides
what the people can see and china
controls 100 of their media
the question is the bigger question
really is are we becoming china
that's really the bigger question i mean
this this has been going on in china
forever china doesn't like something
you don't see it if you're a chinese
citizen they control what all their
citizens see
this is the nature of being under a
dictatorship that they have
the question is is that what we have
here i mean you got you got a company
like
they canceled uh my pillow i mean what
the hell is that i mean this guy's just
got an opinion and all of a sudden now
all these stores are throwing his
merchandise they won't carry his
merchandise at bed bath and beyond and
all these stores decide they're not
going to carry his stuff
because he's a conservative it's
ridiculous absolutely ridiculous and i
don't really care what happens in china
we know
this is not news in china they do this
all the time the question is are we
becoming china
do you actually think we're becoming
china uh we're taking steps in that
direction yes
because we're banning the my pillow guy
it's not just that
cancel culture is by the way have you
ever used a pillow i have not it's not
that good
it's a pillow relax adam yes
forget about canceling the my pillow
again we're canceling the president's
interview with his
daughter i already took a stance on that
i don't agree with that that's what
china does if china doesn't want
something to be heard they just shut it
down okay so
you guys have been in america longer
than i have i've only been here since
1990. you've been here
your entire life you've been here your
entire life minus that one stint when
you went out of the country to addison
texas
outside of that you've been here
greatest place on earth never seen
anything like this
okay that's what i was going to ask you
you've never seen anything ever since
what's been the closest to today
anything has anything been coming
was reagan ever silenced was nick was
nixon silence like
let's put a nixon could nixon get on tv
do an interview and they would show it
always they've never silenced so what's
worse what nixon did or what trump did
which particularly speaking the
reputation the reputation
the way nixon's career ended versus the
way trump's
career ended as a president as of right
now okay
the media the way they sold the story to
the public
okay the way the media sold the story to
the public versus what really happened
okay
here's what trump did he is terrible
he's a divisive guy he's this he's that
okay
nixon watergate you know control doesn't
let anybody in he doesn't talk to
anybody he's a hermit he's this he's
that he's that
it's hard to compare those those are so
different the the point i'm trying to
make to is the following the point i'm
trying to make to use the following
which one had more of an argument to say
he shouldn't get the platform to speak
on tv nixon or trump neither you can't
you can't ever say you don't get the
platform you can't say you can't speak
on tv
this is what our is also exactly what
i'm saying it's neither one of them so
the point
the point i'm trying to make to use
right now today's era that we've had
today for me all i know is last 31 years
i don't know nothing past 31 years okay
you go past 31 years
could any president get on and just give
their speech and give their thoughts a
past president and say
here's what i think about what's going
on was there any time where anyone was
silenced no
ever i can't remember forget about 31
years we're talking about the last
six months so it's not like trump was
silenced
in 2020 he was silenced since
january of 2021 we're talking three four
months ago no no wait a minute
people with silence beginning fact
checked
yeah beginning anything he said no since
november since he lost the election
no no no no he was he started anything
he would post
saying watch them use this against me
from that moment on they would always
fax him at the bottom saying hey this is
not
so from october he started getting
pushed around by social media by the way
i have no problem with fact checks i
don't know by the way
is there such a thing on social media as
as does any
of the social media platforms facebook
twitter and
do they employ any conservative fact
checkers is there a single one
fact checking the left i don't know
whatever the hell
qualification uh situation you have to
be a lefty i don't think that's the
i think there are there's two people
that go into it or lefty stop it i don't
think that you
i'm a lefty i'm coming to work for
google i don't think that's how it works
i think they they're looking for
qualified candidates
you okay got it so going back to it
you've never seen nothing like this
before without listen people have
boycotted
okay companies for things they don't
like i remember uh it was maybe 15
20 years ago they they were going to
play the masters and
since the since the augusta national had
no women members
there was a women's group i can't
remember who it was that headed it up
and they said we're boycotting we're
boycotting you know they were they were
marching outside
and they what they did was they decided
we're going to try to get them to not
buy the products
for from cadillac or ibm or those and
then
what the master said was what augusta
nationals said was fine you don't want
to buy
tell you what we're not going to take
any advertising this year that way you
don't you can boycott all you want
do whatever and you know eventually it
went away but to to literally cancel
someone say you can't be you you can't
be in our store i mean corporations to
start to start pandering to
to it's just insanity well speaking of
uh
hi jen we have appearance by jennifer
bet david yeah i mean this doesn't
what's going on here don't you say hello
to everybody real quick on chat come on
camera say hi
how many weeks do we have left babe how
many weeks we got left
um so i'm 28 weeks on saturday 12.
so yeah we got two how are you feeling
you feeling good yes
yeah she's sitting last night doing
homework with the kids
we had to uh work with tico yesterday on
how to write
what he learned by the way good story on
what what i told tico she was there this
was a hilarious story yeah
so uh i feel uncomfortable you standing
up babe but i'll tell the story
so so here's what happened yesterday
it's a funny story yeah
so tico has a hard time reading
and putting what he read on paper he
doesn't like to do that he just likes to
read give him a book he reads through
two three books
you give it to him he'll be done with it
right so he's reading this jackie
kennedy book and i said so what did you
learn from the book so he writes
her jackie kennedy's husband was a
former senator
his next sentence is they lived in
such-and-such two sentences i'm like you
gotta give me more than this i said let
me ask you a question do you ever wanna
make movies he says yeah
i said you're gonna write scripts with
movies he says of course i said when you
write scripts about a movie what
spielberg wants some of these guys would
do is it's all about details
you got to give details he says give me
an example i said let me write a script
for you
he says what's that i said so one day
this boy
walks out in a backyard when he goes in
the backyard he hears a noise and a
shadow
it's dark he can't see anything he opens
the door to go to the backyard
all of a sudden hear something run to
the side so he looks to the right
he's wondering what it is as he walks
closer to the chair
he sees a splash in the water sees a
shadow under the water moving
looks over there to see what it is he
hears a sound to the right again
i said that's what you got to do he says
continue with the story
so what happened what was in the world
i'm like the point i'm trying to make he
said no no go continue so i'm like i got
to finish
it so he moves the chair cockroach jumps
out
so it's okay it's nothing crazy then he
gets closer to the pool
he looks over the water he sees the
shadow moving next thing you know
someone behind him pushes him in the
pool then when he falls in the pool it's
dark
he sees this shadow swing up to him
guess what it was
what it was his dad playing a prank on
it oh what a great story that i said now
write it like that this was yesterday
two days ago with tico
but anyways thank you for this and fyi
so everybody knows is this coffee
no does your husband drink coffee no
okay so does your husband need coffee
no not at all that's the real
it's called a questions fog they make it
a starbucks it's
tea mixed with hot milk and some a few
pumps of vanilla
mixed with a it's always comes with
lipstick on it just so you know mine
always comes
every day i get i'm like well she took a
sip out of it
like a sexy cup of tea to make sure they
did it right so i
taste both of them she's the canary in
the coal mine yeah she is
can we give a quick shout out to jen for
a second i don't know what you're doing
with your skin but like
you've it's incredible you're glowing
zero blemishes no it's probably
pregnancy
is that what it is that was my next
thing i never got to try it you ought to
get pregnant
see what happens to you i'll see what i
can do that's what they say they say it
makes you glow
i'm like well you know i'll take it well
your skin looks ridiculous
so awesome thank you baby thank you okay
so where will we
nice little appearance well let me see
cancel culture okay but
i think we were right at uh the point
where they're they're um
canceling h
i don't think this is where the american
people are i don't think the american
people like canceled culture i don't
think them liking
i don't like them canceling comedians
anything i mean a guy like don rickles
could not survive today that's just
couldn't do it
well look at that look at our friend
bill burr he's somehow making it out
there
very few but there's an interesting
youtube video about billboard we're
talking about yesterday how
this one guy has analyzed how he does it
and how he comes to both sides and he
brings
people in and when he realizes that he's
stepped in due to he
he knows how to get out of it very
quickly by
either self-deprecation or he does
something i'm a comedian i'm a comedian
i mean it's the best it's the comedian
defense pat's looking into that from
what i understand
i won't mind doing it you have no idea
how much i'm looking forward to doing
one day
i go five ten minutes at a local club
here i show an appearance opening
and then if i like it i may do it once a
month who knows if i like it oh you're
gonna like it
if i like it i'm going to do it because
here's the good thing here's what's
going to happen
because you're going to do it and
there's going to be one of two outcomes
you're either going to crush it clearly
because you're
yeah awesome at this and you're going to
get a taste of it you're like i want to
do that again
or you're going to bomb and you're gonna
say i
freaking can't go out like that i gotta
come back that's a regard
so what are you banking on do a bomb or
killing it crush it i think you're gonna
crush it and you're gonna get a feel for
damn this is funny
yeah and then here's the documentary
another thing to my list of things
when you when you because i did comedy
for many many years and then i got into
finance and you know i still and i
opened up a comedy club at south beach
shout out to bodega shout out to ricky's
um you can always say
well i was joking i'm a comedian like
it's a great defense
guys don't take me seriously i'm you
know i'm joking over here um
jon stewart got away kind of like kind
of kind of like louis louis ck
last saturday night live but last point
just about h m boycotting
can you remember a few years ago they
came out with a shirt they were all up
in the news they
they had um a little black kid cute
little black guy
uh 10 year old kid and the shirt
ironically was
coolest monkey in the jungle do you
remember this
ridiculous situation that they had you
know what i'm laughing at i'm laughing
at the guy saying adam would cancel pbd
on twitter if he got him an extra 100
000 followers joseph smith
to cancel joe yeah go ahead so this was
a big deal for h m this is
i think this happened maybe okay how
ridiculous is that cute little kid maybe
six years old
coolest monkey in the jungle are you
flipping freaking
kidding me so they had to walk that back
apologize all that
so ever since then they've definitely
taken a baby is this a spoof or this is
not a spoof this is real life this is
actually the shirt
wait that this cannot be real this is
real and that was the model they used
yes yeah try doing that today how much
what year is this i'm actually i'm
guessing 2018
i'm guessing and nothing happened to
them oh no no no no
backlash boycott all that so obviously
in the last
two or three years they said holy
we gotta
clean up our act a little bit is that
ridiculous or not that's you don't know
about this story well let me tell you
whoever was the cmo to market or ought
to be fireball
they were if if you have half a
brain you ought to know that just makes
no sense right there ridiculous yeah um
so what was your what was your outcome
what was this wrong what's my point so
obviously h
m had to kind of get woke whoa and they
had to basically start taking stances on
things like china because this whole
story
started with basically they're speaking
up against human rights in china which
obviously i totally agree with byron
you know you either play ball with china
you stfu shut up
and get or get out of the way lose your
funding get canceled and potentially
disappear like our friend jack ma
but the the the bigger question here
with china
and h m is you ever shopped at h
m never been there oh maybe once
my favorite store to shop at are you
kidding me i know it's your favorite
store
that's the best deal in the anyone who
needs new clothes
and they're like well i'm not sure where
to go because i'm all about save that
money
h m is read you can go there and spend
300 bucks and have an entire new
wardrobe
it's amazing so shout out to h m just
don't get those sweaters with the
clothes
what percentage of the population do you
think is if they had to vote
thumbs up or thumbs down on where the
country's going in terms of
wokeness and being for more wokeness
or less wokeness where do you think the
country i think the country's like yeah
we got to get more woke or the country
is
most people like this is such a bunch of
crap
the majority of people are not in the
woke camp is what i'm assuming
in the wool camp or do they agree with
it i think they need to learn cancer
is a fad and it will be
phased out you know as as all this stuff
but don't forget
don't forget byron when you were 20
years old you were voting for freaking
jimmy carter you were hippie you were
smoking grass whatever you were doing
now you're conservative with money
smoking weed but go ahead i said grass
yeah
um so things change over time so
i think we'll just say what is
politically correct
changes over overtime in the 1960s what
was politically correct
was to hate the war be against the war
march against the war
he turned out to be the freaking right i
understand peace love but
our veterans came back and they were
treated just
it was embarrassing i think it's
horrible unbelievable
so embarrassing almost makes me want to
cry i mean it is so embarrassing the way
we treated our veterans
and that's what was politically correct
and it's just it
and that and nowadays you thank them for
their service even vietnam vets you go
back and say you know my god you really
you went a lot of people didn't go they
went to canada they got some sort of
bone spur or whatever
everybody's got an excuse my point is
that political correctness changes
there's nothing there's no immutable
truth and they act like oh my god this
you that's you can't say that you can't
do that you
you do that you're gonna get canceled
you need to do you do get canceled
people worry about being canceled people
worry about mistakes they've made
i don't believe that when people make
mistakes they should not be able to earn
a living
i think they should pay the price for
their mistakes and they should be able
to earn a living i don't think you
should cancel a comedian
i mean i don't think he should cancel
louis c.k for whatever he did i don't
think he should cancel kevin spacey for
what he did
if he committed a crime let him pay the
price for the crime but he's a great
actor
let him act i mean he's good at what he
does i don't i just don't think it's
fair to
cancel people's ability to support their
families and do what they do
just to make your point who's who's the
question is
who's making those decisions of being
afraid to
you know sit there and say yeah let's go
and shut down let's go ahead and cancel
this thing here because we're going to
get so much backlash
that's that's who the problem is the
problem is who's caving in
that who's caving that's the problem the
problem
isn't right the problem isn't
complaining that's been going on for
thousands of years
right the problem is a kid comes
complaining to dad and says
you won't realize what the other one did
oh my gosh what did they do are you
kidding me the teacher said this
let me call the teacher right now they
will never talk to my son like this ever
again like hypothetically right
right so it's the parents that's the
fault not the complainer
i think the complainer is never going to
we have been conditioned to become
offended by just about everything
and it's just annoying as hell the only
thing that offends me really truly
offends me or upsets me about
is when someone gets offended or upset
or triggered about something that's not
worth getting triggered about
that's that's what offends me like what
do you get over it give me a break
i mean you see all these sports teams
changing their names
they're caving to cancel culture if you
will i mean
with washington redskins i mean
you heard what happened of course you
know wft
finally finally after after all these
years uh
you know you what's with dan snyder i
think his name is he finally did you
hear his speech when he changed
when he decided he said yeah you know i
after all these years i've been hearing
on pressure and pressure and pressure
we don't want to you know we don't want
to offend anybody anymore so
moving forward starting monday the
washington redskins are now just going
to be known as
the redskins so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you